el mayor riesgo de la vida es no
arriesgarse
esa frase me viene a la mente cada vez
que tengo que tomar una decisión
complicada una decisión difícil en mi
vida la última de ellas la decisión de
emprender un negocio de comprar una
empresa y lanzarme a hablar de temas de
felicidad de cultura organizacional y de
liderazgo cuando tomé esa decisión me
llamaron dos amigos el primero de ellos
muy optimista me dijo oye jorge no crees
que es una muy mala idea estar haciendo
esto ahora que el país está en una
situación tan complicada el segundo de
ellos todavía más optimista me dijo yo
creo que le está regando eso no es lo
tuyo que se me hace que esta es la peor
decisión que has tomado en tu vida pues
bien pese a todas esas opiniones esta
frase que les digo el mayor riesgo de la
vida es no arriesgarse regresaba a mi
mente a cada minuto esta frase me la
dijo mi abuelo el contador miguel torres
que en paz descanse y quien como ustedes
se pueden imaginar es el héroe de esta
historia
es un héroe cómo se define a un héroe un
héroe pues de acuerdo al real y el
diccionario de la real academia es
definido como aquella que persona que es
recordada y que es famosa por sus
hazañas a mí me gusta referirme a los
héroes como aquella persona que llega a
tu vida para que crezcas para que
avances y para que te vaya mejor les voy
a pedir que hagamos un ejercicio por
favor cierren los ojos y piensen en su
héroe quién es esa persona en la
historia de tu vida que llegó para que
tú pudieras estar aquí el día de hoy
para que pudieras conseguir los
objetivos que se alcanzado para que
pudieras reinventarte y ahora tráelo
mentalmente invita lo que se siente a un
lado de ti en esta plática porque vamos
a platicar con él un ratito a lo largo
de ella
pues bien aquí se necesita para ser un
héroe esa es la primera pregunta bueno
pues nadie da lo que no tiene así que lo
primero que requiere un héroe es cuidar
de sí mismo estar bien consigo mismo
adam grant que es uno de los principales
escritores en este tema habla que hay
dos clases o tres clases de personas
para ser exactos los cibers o dadores
los takers o tomadores y los masters o
igualadores los dadores pues son la
gente que se desvive por darle a los
demás los tomadores los que están
buscando siempre ver qué sacan y los
igualadores son aquellas personas que te
dan en la medida que reciben algo a
cambio se hizo un análisis para
determinar a cuál de ellos les iba mejor
en la vida en los trabajos en sus
empresas y el estudio arrojó algo bien
interesante arrojó que los dadores los
gamers que solamente se preocupan por
dar a los demás es a los que peor les
iba
después inclusive peor que a los
tomadores ya los igualadores eran los
dadores que primero daban así a sí
mismos que cuidaban de sí mismos que
cuidaban de estar bien consigo mismos
para después darle a los demás a los que
mejor les iba en todos los ámbitos pues
bien si se trata de cuidar de sí mismo
primero que de nadie y ser el héroe de
ti mismo primero que de otras personas
entonces hay que responder qué hago para
estar bien conmigo mismo cierto pues
bien echamos mano de otro de nuestros
autores favoritos tal ben sahar profesor
de harvard en temas de felicidad y él
decía que en la búsqueda por esta
felicidad puedes adoptar cualquiera de
estas dos posturas ser un perfeccionista
o ser un optimista un perfeccionista es
aquella persona que de alguna manera no
acepta otro resultado más que el 10 pues
díaz o no quiere nada o es negro o es
blanco o es todo o es nada estas
personas sufren mucho estas personas se
frustran constantemente porque no
consiguen las cosas como ellos las
esperan una óptima lista en cambio en ti
que toda decisión tiene algo bueno y
tiene algo malo y que hay que saber
vivir con lo malo en la medida que sea
óptimo para ti en ese momento entonces
la gente que verdaderamente logre estar
bien consigo mismo no son los
perfeccionistas son los óptima listas
otro de los autores que habla del tema
mou gawdat explica que el ser humano
atraviesa por cinco estados en la
búsqueda de esta felicidad primero estás
en el estado de confusión en el que no
sabes para dónde ir donde estás perdido
realmente en el que no encuentras hacia
dónde dirigir tus esfuerzos y cualquier
destello que se parezca a la felicidad
ya sea una pareja un trabajo lo agarras
y te abrazas de él confundido como estás
pensando que ahí lo vas a encontrar
pasas por el estado de sufrimiento en el
que te das cuenta que te equivocaste y
que ahí no estaba tu felicidad no estaba
en la pareja que pensabas no estaba en
el trabajo que esperabas no estaba
cambiarte de domicilio y empiezas a
sufrir y te das cuenta que ni modo te
toca sufrir y te estacionas hay un rato
hasta que llegas al estado de escape en
el que usas algunas trampas como el
alcohol las drogas el sexo los deportes
extremos parezca parte de eso que te
hace sufrir y pues lo tienes que repetir
muchas veces para mantenerte en ese
estado de escape porque la cruda pues la
cruz es durísima
hasta que entiendes que no es escapando
t de dónde estás lo que te da la
felicidad y entras a este estado de
felicidad en el que aceptar las cosas
como son
dejas de ver fantasmas deje de hacer de
atribuir tu felicidad a las personas a
las cosas y a los lugares y entiendes
que la felicidad está en ti y en aceptar
las cosas como son pero hay un estado
mayor de felicidad que es el estado de
gozo pleno en el que cuando llegas ahí
te das cuenta que hay que además hacer
una inmersión en eso y fluir y disfrutar
la vida en esas circunstancias pues bien
si se trata entonces de no
necesariamente alcanzar la perfección y
de atravesar por situaciones que no son
las óptimas entonces que me tengo que
conformar tengo que decir bueno hasta
aquí puedo llegar lo voy a buscar la
perfección no voy a buscar algo mejor
pues miren este es el gran dilema que es
más importante mi éxito o la felicidad
ustedes qué piensan tú vas a ser feliz
el día que seas exitoso
o vas a ser exitoso porque lo que haces
te hace muy feliz ustedes que piensan lo
primero lo segundo lo segundo cierto
pues bien si lo segundo es lo importante
entonces hay que tratar de entender pues
que nos hace feliz es cierto de acuerdo
a la ciencia de la felicidad hay tres
cosas que hacen al ser humano feliz el
placer la pasión y el propósito el
placer como ustedes pueden ver en esta
gráfica te genera felicidad cierto ya lo
vimos no un chocolate la diversión una
buena fiesta el sexo las drogas etcétera
te genera placer pero dura poquito de
hecho hay cosas que duran más poquito
que otras verdad
la pasión que es estar en un estado en
el que el tiempo pasa volando les ha
ocurrido en el que está en un tema que
les encanta tanto que se les va el día y
de pronto ya se hizo de noche ni cuenta
te diste eso te genera muchísima mayor
felicidad cómo encontrar la pasión y ese
es un problema so pues miren dicen y no
sé si se alcance a ver ahí que para
encontrar ese estado que se llama el
estado de flow o donde fluye es es donde
el reto y tu capacidad
coinciden si tú tienes un reto muy
grande y tu capacidad es muy chica te
frustras si tú tienes una capacidad muy
grande y un reto muy chico te aburres
entonces tienes que buscar ese punto en
el que confluyan eso que amas con lo que
eres bueno de acuerdo pues bien lo que
más felicidad genera porque la pasión
genera dopamina por eso cuando estás
enamorado apasionado por alguien haces
tantas tonterías verdad pero lo que
mayor felicidad genera es alcanzar tu
propósito en la vida aquello que vas a
dejarle al mundo cuando te vayas tu
legado está es la materia prima de los
héroes
pues dicho lo anterior déjenme
platicarles una historia cuando yo
trabajaba como director de recursos
humanos en cinépolis tuve la oportunidad
de hacer un concurso en el que le
preguntamos a todos los cine politos que
cariñosamente así se llama el personal
que trabaja en cinépolis cine politos
que nos contaran cómo vivían su
propósito y que denunciarán
positivamente a aquellas personas que
mejor lo vivieran el segundo lugar de
este concurso fue manuel déjenme se los
presentó
manuel colaborador del área de baños en
cinépolis mérida 72 años de edad
este señor decía que él tenía dos
sueldos el sueldo con el que vivo y el
sueldo por el que vivo cuando yo
entrevisté a manuel para preguntarle por
qué lo habían nominado me dijo miren
licenciados que es muy fácil yo limpio
mi baño 26 veces por hora mi baño no el
baño del cine no el baño de cinépolis mi
baño 26 veces por hora ustedes imaginan
lo que es limpiar un baño 26 veces por
hora en un estreno tipo avengers'
imagínense nada más eso pues el señor no
solamente lo limpiaba 26 veces por hora
sino que reservaba unos minutitos para
pararse afuera de su baño
recibir a todo el mundo como si
estuviera entrando al mejor hotel de
lujo
y parar la orejita para escuchar lo que
la gente decía de su baño
hijo licenciado el sueldo por el que
vivo es mi libreta y me entrego esa
libreta cuando la leí decía cosas tan
simpáticas como hijo el este baño está
mejor que el de mi casa y cualquier
cantidad de cosas que ustedes se pueden
imaginar el señor estaba viendo su
propósito todos los días el señor se
volvió un héroe dentro de la compañía al
grado que tuvimos que reemplazar a todos
los colaboradores del área de baños por
personas de la tercera edad y tenían a
manuel como un ídolo como un héroe pues
bien resulta que estos héroes que estas
personas que nosotros buscamos en todos
lados tienen algunos atributos que hace
que nos acerquemos muchísimo a ellos yo
estos atributos los asocio con los
hábitos de la felicidad y yo digo que
ellos son magos porque tienen la forma
de vivir en este mundo en el que
disfrutan mucho de la vida y además lo
hacen en beneficio de los demás porque
magos porque viven estos temas el
mindfulness el altruismo la gratitud y
el optimismo es el mindfulness el
mindfulness es esta práctica de vivir el
aquí y el ahora
como muy cauda decía y los explicaba
hace un rato estar en este estado de
gozo pleno en el que estás disfrutando
las cosas tal cual son el mindfulness te
ayuda a ser el héroe de ti mismo ya
salvarte de ti de cometer un error de
quedarte en una relación que no te gusta
en un trabajo que no te gusta porque
estás cobrando conciencia plena de lo
que para ti representa quedarte ahí o
moverte todos pasado por ahí tú has
pasado seguramente por momentos en los
que has estado a punto de divorciarse
cierto levante la mano al que le haya
tocado pasar por ahí verdad el que haya
estado queriendo renunciar a un trabajo
que no le gusta verdad levante la mano
cierto todo el mundo hemos pasado por
situaciones que no nos gustan y es como
cruzar un abismo como ustedes ven acá
primero lo niegas dices nombre pues mi
gordito no está tan mal
o no no me trata no tan mal o sea no me
pega a diario
después te enojas te das cuenta que esto
no es una broma y que si te trata mal te
deprimes y te quedas en ese estado de
sufrimiento hasta que aceptas el hecho
brutal de que hay que cambiar y es
brutal por eso la palabra brutal está
ahí el mindfulness te ayuda que lo
aceptes porque te conoces a ti mismo y
entiendes que eso no te gusta entonces
lo intentas te re inventas y cruzas
finalmente el abismo
esa es la m de mago mindfulness el
altruismo ustedes lo conocen
perfectamente bien es el superpoder de
los héroes el dar para los demás ser un
dador como decía adam brand es ser esta
persona que se desboca no por un interés
personal sino por el interés de ver bien
al de enfrente en eso consiste el
altruismo ya la media que es anónimo es
menos mezquino si lo estás haciendo nada
más para purgar sus penas eso no se
llama altruismo se llama culpa
de acuerdo lage la gratitud agradecer
por lo que tienes será alguien de verdad
que todas las noches dice caray hoy
estoy muy bien el día a pesar de que
hubo varias situaciones este en
particular me encantó
conocí hace poco tiempo un amigo
golfista que era un súper fan del golf
yo no soy bueno para esas cosas pero él
de verdad le encanta y yo le pregunté
qué te tiene tan ligado a este deporte
que juegas tantas veces y tan seguido él
me decía mira jorge dos golfistas cuando
empezamos a jugar pues no le pegamos a
nada no le pegamos al pasto la mandamos
lejos la volamos rompemos cristales pero
hay un golpe durante el juego uno que es
tu único golpe bueno del día y ese golpe
es el que le cuentas a todo el mundo
cuando terminas de jugar y es lo que
hace que regreses a jugar al día
siguiente o la semana siguiente y eso es
lo que te hace adicto al golf y entonces
me puse a pensar y dijo jay porque no
podría ser así la vida porque no en la
noche me pongo a pensar cuál fue mi
único golpe bueno del día o mis únicos
golpes buenos del día y lo recuerdo
antes de dormir y quise en una de esas
con algo de suerte me vuelvo adicto a la
vida
esa es la gratitud el optimismo no es
otra cosa que un estado mental de
acuerdo es la decisión consciente de
entender que el problema no es el
problema el problema es tu actitud ante
el problema aquí hay dos clases de
personas en esta vida
los energizer y los chupasangre o los
rangers tú conoces a los chupasangres no
te hagás acuérdate de ellos tu tía
abuela a la que odias ir a ver ya sabes
cuál o tu amigo es el que corrieron hace
poco y que cada vez que vas a comer con
él sales deprimido les digo algo a los
chupasangre les encantan los energizer
si desde que te ven llegar a la empresa
o algún lugar de trabajo te bendicen y
no le viene bien contento te ahorita me
lo niego
a poco no llega ni en cuanto te acercas
con tu sonrisa llena y te empiezan a
contar todo lo malo y te traen ahí hasta
que pues ya estás igual que ellos
y no es que con eso estén mejor lo que
pasa es que ya no están tan solitos a
los energizer se en cambio les encanta
estar con el noray shares les fascina
como que se cargan la pila uno con el
otro poco no conoces a algún amigo
energizer que vas a comer con él y sales
así como quería que veo que anda que que
sigue no eso te pasa cierto oigan si
ustedes son energizer si no me dejarán
mentir a veces se te baja la pila o no
es ahí cuando el héroe entra en acción
porque los héroes son energizer y los
buscas en ese tipo de situaciones dime
si no traigamos por primera vez a tu
héroe de regreso se acuerdan el euro en
lo que pensaron cuántas veces le has
hablado
cuando te sientes caído de energía o
bajo de energía cuantas veces para que
te dé un consejo simplemente para que te
abrace los energizer contagian con la
energía y son buenísimos haciendo es por
eso son los súper es ordinaria aires y
por eso son héroes de acuerdo pero hay
algo adicional además del tema del
optimismo o además de la gratitud además
del mindfulness hay algo más que tienen
los héroes hace algunos años me dentro
una idea bastante tonta la verdad de
aprender a tocar piano es una idea muy
mala porque soy malísimo para eso
también igual que para el gol soy bueno
para la guitarra y para otras cosas pero
pero para piano no
y cuando empecé con este tema como que
mi maestro se desesperaba bastante hasta
que un día yo me enojé le dije average a
que quiere que lo haga bien o que lo
haga rápido
y me dijo que le bajes
este después que lo hagas bien que lo
hagas rápido y con matisse
con matiz como eso
dijo mira rápido a cualquier menso
rápido y bien poquitos rápido bien y con
matiz
y me dejó pensando ahora es gratis no
entiendo dijo a ver que echaría de menos
el mundo sitio dejará de existir aquí
veniste
la pregunta me sembró y entonces me di
cuenta
que don manuel de los baños que mi
abuelo miguel tenían un tremendo matiz y
que hacían que cualquier persona que los
conocía se quedará impregnado de su
matiz y los extrañará y los quisieran
las conversaciones y que quisiera ser
como ellos
los héroes tienen un matiz gigantesco
entonces si tú eres ese héroe lo primero
que tienes preguntar es que echaría de
menos el mundo si yo dejara de existir
que echaría de menos mi familia mis
amigos mi comunidad mi entorno o estoy
aquí nomás como fantasma y si me voy
nadie se da cuenta lo segundo que tienes
que saber es que si tú eres ese héroe
que va a ir a contagiar a otros de esto
lo primero que tienes que hacer es estar
bien contigo después ser una noria yzr y
poner una muy buena actitud entre las
cosas recordando que el problema no es
el problema el problema es tu actitud
ante el problema lo tercero es aceptar
que no todo va a salir bien y que lo
malo es parte de la ecuación oye en cada
decisión vas a tener cosas buenas o
cosas malas
bien y cosas malas disfrutan las buenas
y lo cuarto que tienes que recordar es
que tienes que trabajar fuertemente en
lo que ames en lo que lo que te apasione
y en lo que te deje dinero y debes de
percibir fuertemente ese propósito así
que sí yo creo que tú sí eres ese héroe
yo creo que en ti descubro ese héroe que
yo estoy buscando y si tú encuentras a
otro como tú y si tú crees en esto que
yo creo
avísale que en este mundo se buscan
héroes
[Aplausos]